les plus belles plages des caraïbes
envahies par les algues sargasse comme
ici à cancun au mexique
un cauchemar qui se répète chaque été
depuis presque dix ans dans toute la
région
par exemple en république dominicaine
tout est paradisiaque
excepté les algues qui d'entre eux de
démangeaisons ces algues se forme au
large de l'afrique
elles prolifèrent avant d'atteindre les
côtes caraïbes à l'été 2010 8 la nappe
de sargasses s'étendait sur huit mille
huit cent cinquante kilomètres
un fléau écologique pour la faune marine
qui étouffe comme ces poissons et ses
tortues films et aux antilles mais aussi
un désastre pour l'économie en se
décomposant les sargasses dégage une
odeur pestilentielle qui chasse les
touristes les scientifiques
s'interrogent sur les causes de cette
prolifération
comment ces axes forme pourquoi il y en
a autant est ce à cause de la
température à cause des nutriments du
sable du sahara verbaux et coup de
théorie et de probabilités pour protéger
les plages ses filets anti al inventé
par une entreprise française qui a aussi
développé cette barge de collecte en
république dominicaine cet outil là
c'était un no dig et des ateliers un
tracteur à l'origine et qui a servi à
ramasser les algues vertes en bretagne
reste à trouver des débouchés pour ses
millions de tonnes collectées à cancun
au mexique a appris de la vence il
produit des briques de construction
particulièrement isolante à base de
sarcasmes